[Musique]
salut à tous le 24 septembre prochain ou
dernier selon le moment où vous regardez
cette vidéo la moitié du sénat sera ou a
été réglé je vous propose à cette
occasion de nous pencher sur le rôle
réel de cette institution
vous êtes certainement appris en
éducation civique ou dans des émissions
pédagogiques que le rôle du sénat était
de représenter les collectivités
territoriales communes départements et
régions et bien cette explication est un
peu courte
c'est certes celle de la constitution
mais pourtant elle est contradictoire si
le sénat représente les territoires
comme le dit la constitution
alors pourquoi 12 sénateurs sont élus
par les français de l'étranger pour
suffrage universel direct en plus alors
que par définition ils ne vivent pas sur
le territoire national manifestement on
nous cache des choses et pour bien
comprendre la particularité et les
raisons de l'existence du sénat français
je vous propose d'abord de faire un
petit tour d'horizon des différents
systèmes parlementaires
les systèmes parlementaires à travers le
monde sont variés mais on peut les
classer en deux grandes catégories les
systèmes mono gameiro qui ont une seule
chambre d'élus et les systèmes beecham
héros qui en comporte 2 dans ce cas on
estime souvent une chambre basse élu au
suffrage universel direct
une chambre haute qui est élu par un
mode d'élection souvent plus élitiste
pour les systèmes beckham héros on peut
citer les usa ou la chambre des
représentants représente les citoyens et
le sénat représente les états fédérés
sachant que les deux chambres sont élus
au suffrage universel direct
en allemagne le bundestag représente les
citoyens et le bundesrat qui représente
les états fédérés länder les
représentants des länder ne sont pas
élus mais nommés par les gouvernements
régionaux parmi les ministres en espagne
on retrouve à peu près le même schéma
avec un sénat qui représente les régions
les communautés autonomes et une chambre
de députés représentant les citoyens
le royaume uni dispose lui aussi de deux
chambres et le pays reconnaissant de
classe sociale la chambre des communes
représentent les simples citoyens et la
chambre des lords représente la noblesse
voilà en tout cas pour les systèmes
beckham héros parmi les systèmes mono
gameiro complicité le venezuela la grèce
la turquie ou encore les pays
scandinaves finlande norvège et suède
le choix d'opter pour un fonctionnement
mono ou bicaméral peut paraître un peu
aléatoire et de fait c'est aussi un
produit de l'histoire particulière de
chaque pays
mais en y regardant de plus près il ya
quand même une sorte de logique dans le
choix des institutions législatives
ce n'est pas une science exacte mais on
peut diviser les états en deux
catégories fédéraux et unitaire les
états fédéraux sont des états constituée
d'états ou de régions fédérées qui se
réunissent pour former l'état central
c'est une forme d'association les états
aux régions fédérées et l'état fédéral
ont chacun leurs prérogatives que
l'autre ne peut pas s'accaparer la
souveraineté est partagée dans les états
unis terre par contre une seule entité
possède toute la souveraineté la france
en est l'archétype
on a bien des subdivisions territoriales
les communes les régions et les
départements
mais en fait c'est l'état qui les créent
s'il le veut il peut aussi bien
administré lui-même le territoire par
exemple la ville de paris a été gérée
directement par l'état via la préfecture
jusqu'en 1977 et n'avait pas de mère
également autre exemple en 2014
l'état a décidé unilatéralement de
refonder les régions personnes
régional n'a été consulté dans un état
fédéral ce serait totalement impossible
ce serait une atteinte à la souveraineté
des entités fédérées
si on applique cette distinction état
fédéral états unis terre à nos exemples
on voit que les états fédéraux sont
souvent gameiro dans les états fédéraux
le bicamérisme est logique puisqu'il
faut représenter les personnes physiques
les citoyens et les personnes morales
les états pour régions fédérées
constituant l'état fédéral et ce
fonctionnement de fait est quasiment une
norme dans les états unis terre le mono
camériste serait logique qu'il n'y a que
les citoyens représentés puisque les
subdivisions territoriales ne sont que
les émanations de l'état est représenté
les collectivités locales comme c'est le
prétexte pour l'existence du sénat en
france est une aberration l'état
unitaire n'est qu'une machine au service
des citoyens et représenter les entités
que l'état crée lui-même et dont il
définit des prérogatives est paradoxale
ça revient un peu à donner le droit à la
parole à une machine que nous utilisons
l'aberration qui représente le
bicamérisme et dans les états unis terre
est d'ailleurs connu certains pays
initialement gameiro comme les pays
scandinaves sont devenus monocaméral
dans la première moitié du 20e siècle
en france aussi on sait que duke améris
m'impose un problème démocratique et par
exemple en 1998 lionel jospin alors
premier ministre en fonction déclaré
dans une interview qu'une chambre comme
le sénat dans un état unitaire comme la
france n'avait pas de sens mais alors si
c'est une anomalie connu pourquoi at on
créé le sénat et surtout pourquoi le
maintien ton
l'existence du sénat remonte à loin
puisqu'en france depuis 1789
le pays a toujours compté deux chambres
de fait le sénat a toujours servi à
contrer l'assemblée nationale que ce
soit la fin du 19e siècle pour contenter
les royalistes ou sous la vème
république pour satisfaire les envies de
stabilité de de gaulle et d'un point de
vue philosophique
on doit cet attachement sénat a monté ce
qu'une montesquieu s'est intéressé à la
notion de pouvoir
on lui doit entre autres le classement
des pouvoirs en trois catégories
judiciaire législatif et exécutif
il a aussi établi une théorie basée sur
un principe simple le pouvoir arrête le
pouvoir pour éviter la tyrannie les
trois pouvoirs doivent être entre des
mains différentes être organisée de
façon à se neutraliser entre eux c'est
le principe de séparation des pouvoirs
si chère aux démocraties libérales et si
on regarde de près le fonctionnement des
institutions françaises
on s'aperçoit que ce principe s'applique
souvent d'abord entre les pouvoirs le
pouvoir législatif peut destituer un
gouvernement par le vote d'une motion de
censure il exécutif peut dissoudre le
parlement mais cette logique s'applique
aussi à l'intérieur de chaque pouvoir au
sein du pouvoir exécutif le président a
besoin de la signature du premier
ministre pour un certain nombre d'actes
et vice versa ainsi un président peut
bloquer une action du premier ministre
s'il refuse de signer dans la pratique
ça arrive très rarement
c'est arrivé en période de cohabitation
en 1986 quand mitterrand a refusé de
signer des ordonnances rédigé par chirac
visant à privatiser des entreprises
publiques et bien sûr et c'est le
prétexte initial de cette vidéo le sénat
et l'assemblée nationale se
contrebalancent une l'autre notamment
lors de la rédaction des lois les
projets devant faire consensus
un consensus souvent établis au prix de
longs et pénibles les allers retours
entre les deux assemblées
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle le
sénat est élu au suffrage indirect pour
contrebalancer une chambre élue au
suffrage universel direct
il vaut mieux un autre mode d'élection
sinon les deux chambres vont avoir la
même couleur politique
au final à cette logique de
neutralisation des pouvoirs un prix
fortement nos institutions et une partie
de la classe politique
d'ailleurs dans son interview de 1998
jospin déclaré qu'une chambre comme le
sénat avec autant de pouvoir était une
anomalie
ce qui laisse sous-entendre qu'il ne
serait pas opposé à un sénat aux
pouvoirs réduits comme c'est
généralement le cas dans les autres pays
gameiro mais la réforme du sénat tout
comme la proportionnelle aux
législatives est l'une des arlésiennes
de la vie politique française aussi bien
pour des questions d'équilibré politique
et pour des questions philosophiques
comme on vient de le voir et son
évolution voire sa suppression comme
dans les pays scandinaves n'est
probablement pas près d'arriver
et bien voilà maintenant
vous connaissez les raisons
philosophiques de l'existence du sénat
en france c'est cette vidéo vous a plu
vous invite à lâcher un pouce bleu voire
à vous abonner
je vous donne rendez-vous pour une
prochaine vidéo d'ici là je vous dis
portez vous bien et à la prochaine
[Musique]